en estas imágenes tenemos una vista
frontal semi transparente de un hombre y
esta es una vista posterior semi
transparente de una mujer los órganos
representados secretan moléculas en el
torrente sanguíneo y a los órganos que
secretan algo se les conoce como
glándulas las glándulas secretan
diferentes moléculas al torrente
sanguíneo que regulan otras partes del
cuerpo y que se encuentran muy lejos de
las glándulas que la secretar y a esas
moléculas que regulan otras partes del
cuerpo se les llama hormonas la palabra
hormona proviene de la palabra griega
hormona que significa poner en
movimiento así que una forma de verlo es
que las hormonas son moléculas que ponen
cosas en movimiento en otras partes del
cuerpo y esto sirve para regular el
funcionamiento del cuerpo ahora al
sistema de glándulas se les conoce como
sistema endocrino en dos se refiere al
hecho de que actúa dentro del cuerpo y
que no proviene originalmente de la
palabra griega utiliza
para referirse a secretar algo así que
es un sistema de órganos o mejor dicho
de glándulas que secretan moléculas
conocidas como hormonas al torrente
sanguíneo para regular el cuerpo no voy
a profundizar mucho en todas las
glándulas endocrinas pero sólo para que
podamos conocer un poco de lo que hace y
de qué se tratan sus hormonas vamos a
mencionar algunas de las más comunes por
ejemplo la glándula tiroides produce
hormonas tiroideas esta es una versión
de la hormona tiroidea aquí podemos ver
que los carbonos están representados de
color gris oscuro los hidrógenos de
color blanco los oxígenos de color rojo
el nitrógeno de color azul y estos
átomos grandes son yodo las hormonas
tiroideas juegan un papel muy importante
en nuestro metabolismo de hecho si
tenemos muchas hormonas tiroideas
podemos tener un desorden conocido como
hipertiroidismo que provoca que el
metabolismo esté hiperactivo y por el
contrario si tenemos pocas hormonas
tiroideas
podemos tener un desorden conocido como
hipotiroidismo en donde el metabolismo
no es lo suficientemente activo por otro
lado también tenemos otras hormonas como
la adrenalina que es producida por las
glándulas suprarrenales aunque a la
adrenalina también se le conoce como
epinefrina y tal vez hayan escuchado
decir que su tanito es adicto a la
adrenalina lo que significa que le gusta
vivir al límite y la adrenalina juega un
papel en todo esto está muy involucrada
en la reacción de pelea o huida en donde
incrementa la frecuencia cardíaca y
aumenta el flujo sanguíneo en los
músculos lo más interesante sobre todo
esto es que todas estas hormonas tienen
muchos impactos en el cuerpo porque son
liberados al torrente sanguíneo y cada
célula puede hacer diferentes cosas
ahora tenemos al estrógeno que se
produce principalmente en los ovarios
pero también existe en el cuerpo
masculino y está asociado con muchas de
las funciones del cuerpo femenino aunque
como acabo de decir
no debe ser estrictamente femenino el
estrógeno también existe en los varones
de manera similar un varón produce
testosterona que está asociada a las
funciones del cuerpo masculino pero
también existe en el cuerpo femenino en
los hombres es producido principalmente
por los testículos por eso el nombre de
testosterona pero también puede ser
producido por las glándulas
suprarrenales y en las mujeres puede ser
producido por los ovarios
también tenemos la insulina que como
podemos ver es mucho más grande que las
otras hormonas la insulina es producida
por el páncreas y juega un papel muy
importante en el procesamiento de los
azúcares y el almacenamiento de grasa de
hecho los científicos constantemente
están descubriendo nuevas funciones de
esta hormona en particular la insulina
está asociada con la diabetes por
ejemplo las personas con diabetes tipo 1
no pueden producir suficiente insulina
para sacar el azúcar de su torrente
sanguíneo y que las
células puedan absorber el azúcar porque
lo que hace la insulina es que se une a
la superficie de una célula para que
pueda tomar el azúcar del torrente
sanguíneo y las personas con diabetes
tipo 2 sufren de insensibilidad a la
insulina por lo que necesitan ingerir
insulina extra para que sus células
tomen la cantidad adecuada de azúcar
pero aquí la idea principal es ver que
el sistema endocrino aunque puede que no
sea tan conocido como el sistema
nervioso juega un papel muy importante
en nuestro cuerpo porque nos ayuda a
regularlo nos ayuda a mantener la
temperatura adecuada la presión
sanguínea correcta y la frecuencia
cardíaca normal una forma de pensar en
esto es con la noción de homeostasis que
se refiere a asimilar y estar igual
entonces al mantener nuestro cuerpo a la
temperatura correcta sin importar la
temperatura en el exterior o lo que esté
haciendo el cuerpo hay muchas funciones
que realizan todas estas hormonas que
son producidas por las glándulas
crines hemos terminado pero nos vemos en
otro vídeo